rooks move vertically and horizontally
bishops move diagonally
the queen moves like a rook and a bishop
knights move one square like a rook and
one square like a bishop
pawns move forward one square on their
first move they may move two squares
they capture
one square four diagonally if a pawn
reaches the opposite rank
it promotes a pawn that moves two
squares forward
may be captured by an enemy pawn as if
it had moved one square
kings move one square in any direction
the board is set up with a white square
on each player's right
queens on color and pieces placed from
tallest to smallest
white moves first players may castle by
moving their king two squares toward a
rook and placing the rook on the
opposite side
the goal of the game is checkmate to
place the opposing king
in an attack from which there is no
legal escape